Making smart energy choices has become a way of life.
Energy-saving bulbs, efficient windows,...
...sealing all the gaps around doors,...
...these are all smart choices.
But what about the choices we make before a home is even built?
How green a building is depends in part...
...on the materials used to build it.
Homes today are made of three common building materials:...
...wood, steel and concrete.
Wood may not be best for all buildings,...
...but it does have many environmental advantages.
Let's investigate: wood is a naturally renewable building material.
Trees renew naturally from seed or are replanted by land managers...
...which means we basically can have wood products forever.
Trees pull carbon out of the air and hold on to it.
Gotcha.
Even after trees are made into lumber panels or furniture,...
...the wood is still keeping carbon out of our atmosphere.
Wood products require less water and energy to produce.
Compared to wood, concrete requires 16 to 50% more energy to produce,...
...and the production of steel requires 25 to 90% more energy than wood,...
...and as much as 400% more water...
...and the production of wood emits less carbon dioxide...
...than steel or concrete.
And finally, wood can often be grown and produced locally...
...instead of across the country or across the world.
Way to go Washington.
So how do you choose the greenest building material?
Easy, it's the one that's green.
And that's the story on green building.